Chuck Todd was on Larry Kings
politicking and my buddy Larry King
asked him some interesting questions and
Chuck had this to say which I thought
was kind of insightful about big money
in all of this the Supreme Court
decision allowing anything goes
literally didn't that have a great
effect on all of us
well I think it's all having a
cumulative impact and here's the
unintended consequence so you have all
this money if you're a candidate Larry
and you want to run for office
you've got to suddenly not just see if
you've got enough friends to write your
checks that'll add up to a couple
million dollars you have to find out if
you have a sugar daddy or sugar mommy
that can write you a check for a billion
dollars or knows people that can
accumulate a billion dollars oh by the
way what you want to run on you may not
be able to run on because some outside
group may decide they want you they're
gonna make your campaign about issue X
even if you want to talk about issue why
I think this whole process it's the
money it's it's media social media
opposition research the destructive
nature of American discourse is you
havin an accumulating effect that drives
good people from running for office and
I think we're having a collective you
know I sort of joke that I feel like the
collective IQ of Congress goes down
every two years because smart people
look at it and say why do I want to do
this Wow I actually am feeling a little
vindicated money media social media it's
all part of the problem holy cow this is
what we say everyday right this is what
we do all the time and we're outside of
the system so we can be honest about it
is it a little too late for Chuck Todd
to join the truth training Chuck Todd is
part of the problem I mean who the [ __ ]
is he kidding are you kidding that guy
couldn't be a bigger corporatist i watch
his show it's I've lost weight from
growing up it's unbelievable
I mean he's that for him to say and then
for him to kind of mix everything
together like he just did you're also
doing a disservice to the issue
you can't Twitter is not as big a
problem with Sheldon Adelson right that
it's not the biggest problem the Koch
brothers
Sheldon Addison that the fact that our
elections have been hijacked by money is
not a big deal as Joey jaggoff on
right and for him to say the money thing
which obviously we talk about all the
time but then for the next word to be
media when he's in the media which is
NBC owned by GE but he doesn't say
corporate media or why it's the media or
what's wrong with the media
he just says the media yeah right Ben
you've been doing this longer than we
have are you feeling hatred for for
Chuck Todd is much stronger than mine
that mine will grow he's so much better
it would appear to me then then David
Gregory that the no he's definitely
better you're just wrong sometimes
you're just wrong i watch the show i see
clips like it okay so i more informed
than you but you can have your opinion
no no first of all being blessed form
has never stopped you from open your
mouth once and you're absolutely I'm
certainly not back off at this point
nor would bring to meet the price I mean
you got like like I would take a win
sometimes and that's and I think I agree
with Dave if there's a pretty good thing
of Chuck does Larry King
what does Larry King look like in the
morning before the makeup of that it's
like it would be unrecognizable with him
in the morning out of making this code
for something good look you're right he
doesn't but you know when he the fact is
he doesn't say corporatist media but
when he says media that's what that's
what that's what that means to regular
people they don't think media means
Twitter they think media means NBC CBS
ABC CNN and those shows and and it is we
are discreet and then do his bigger
point or we just are smart people
discouraged from running yeah I think so
and what is clear though more so than
smart people being discouraged for
running is dumb people are encouraged to
run and so be nice if he finished the
point because we're Sheldon we're the
Koch brothers and Sheldon Adelson win
are when dumb people run data there's no
they haven't recruited one smart
candidate to run anywhere and so and a
little bit what what you would like
Chuck Todd to get to say is man the crop
of Republican Senate candidates who won
this year those are those they were
better candidates than then in oh then
in 12 or whatever the last year was 12
or 10 there was no Todd akin
you know they weren't they didn't have
guys who were there wasn't a guy
anywhere it was there wasn't Richard you
know Murdock Murdock in Indiana there
weren't those guys so they they were
they were they were more crafted in that
sense but they were Craven and
dim-witted and not big thinkers and
their little tiny people you'd like him
to say that because it's not like George
Soros is going around the country
spending money to recruit dumb
progressives to run right so almost by
default won't the 2016 Republicans have
to be better than last time I mean
really wait where do you think of that
collection with Michelle Bachman and
Rick Perry who may run again and $9.99 a
Herman Cain I mean when you think it
actually seems like SNL parody who they
put up last time so I sort of feel like
it has to be better this time by just
you know worse I can i I'm gonna I'm
gonna reserve my judgment cuz I expect
them to rise us yeah I think they will
be even worse um I think it's gonna be
Rand Paul Chris Christie right and then
Rick Perry just for kicks yeah Kerry
yeah and then Jeb Bush who was not who
was a more serious person sounding he's
more serious sounding he's a more
serious with glasses which is yeah and
if he ends up being more like his father
right then then it's just more sort of
like the Jeb Bush if he's more like his
dad if it were Jeb Bush more like his
dad against Hillary Clinton then I would
honestly for the first time buy into the
argument of there's probably not a lot
of huge difference there Oh between Jeb
Bush and Hillary yeah there wouldn't be
much of a difference at all I don't
think right as opposed to whether it's
Hillary against whether it's Hillary and
ands Rand Paul and Rand Paul or Chris
Christie or Rick Perry or god forbid
Scott Walker any of those guys there's
then there's a dramatic enough
difference it's not the kind of
difference where you're like yay Hillary
but there is a difference where you're
like oh [ __ ] alright well let's let's
not go too deep the rabbit-hole of 2016
but is it is it already too late to talk
about money for 2016 right it is already
right Hillary's been getting you know
raising money for a year at least we
found basically in five years at this
point like nothing can change in terms
of money for the next price
can it like that system isn't like it
the only thing that can maybe change it
in Barack Obama I thought he was gonna
but it turns out was that if you say I'm
not like remember Jerry Brown when he
ran a long time ago he would give out an
800 number and say I'm not taking any
corporate money I'm only taking money
from people that's what it's gonna take
somebody to do that which I thought
Barack Obama was gonna do but he didn't
so that's I think you can that's the
only other way we can change it besides
a constitutional amendment or we get the
Supreme Court changed which it doesn't
look like that's happening right so okay
so the Supreme Court obviously to blame
right with the money there's no doubt
about I don't think anyone really argues
that but is it also Obama's fault cuz
remember in 2008 when he said I'm not
gonna take super PAC money and then
McCain started doing it and then Obama
was like well it wasn't gonna take
pretty much said it and then but then
was like well he's doing it so I have to
and then we got and thank God we don't
live in a world where you could do that
you can't do that now if what Jimmy's
right about is that is that you never
know if someone has the magnetism with
Jerry Brown Jerry Brown's a super
interesting politician but Jerry Brown
did not have the magnetism to take that
off retrieve somebody right if a guy who
had the mass appeal that Barack Obama
did and then it turned out had a
personality of some sort those things
came together and that guy did something
like that well then you never know and
like you know we shouldn't don't sleep
totally on you know that progressives
want Elizabeth Warren I don't I I just I
don't I don't see it happening it seems
unlikely I think she's too close to
Hillary but who knows maybe you harder
if thousands of people demand that you
run for president it's very hard for a
politician to not get caught up in that
moment and go but don't totally sleep on
Jim Webb who you know was Reagan's
Secretary of the Navy or maybe assistant
secretary of the Navy i'ma crack know
right now then became a Democrat didn't
he just launched an exploratory
committee to explore he actually
launched it some time ago he got media
coverage for it this week which was a
little weird but he's an interesting guy
and an interesting guy about war and an
interesting guy about financing and he
thinks that we should have hammered Wall
Street and should have gone at yeah yes
so like and like you know and he's plain
talker and he wears cowboy boots and
he's gonna
and he's got a long history of stuff
that's gonna get him in trouble with
women but that that's it but he's
Democrat which means you get out of it a
little easier all right so last thought
on this would it be hard for you guys to
get excited over anybody because that's
that's how I feel at this point that no
matter I was so excited for Obama the
first time I voted for him twice as I've
said a kajillion times in the show and
now I'm just like so over it when I hear
him speak I'm just like whatever
I know Ben you're not as sour on him but
what would it take for you to really be
excited about a candidate I think that
if the Hispanic from Modern Family ran I
vote for her I get excited I guess I'm
just thinking about it
I watched an episode of that I never saw
it before I was I'm always [ __ ] I'm
getting divorced you get the women vote
you get the Latino vote that's pretty
good what would it take for you to
actually get excited woody I love
getting excited I mean I love this guy I
don't you know the I love talking
politics
I love playing politics I like it when
candidates play politics I'm not
disturbed by the process of the
compromises that people make that's
we've always done that like we've
reached a point where we're where the
compromises to corporate America to Wall
Street have it's too extreme so then it
stopped being so much fun right and
there's no real there's nobody on the
other side making a strong enough
argument so that's a problem but I love
the race and I hope somebody beats
Hillary I do I hope she's not the
candidate with you I mean I hope a
Democrat beats her and gets the
nomination and wins the presidency and
it'll be interesting and I looked it's
something we're we're tipping and we're
still here we're still over here on the
right book but there's a there a lot of
people who are like why aren't we here
so maybe we've you know at some point it
it moves and there might be make one
point about Barack Obama and I certainly
do come down hard on him he has done a
lot of good things he's like he's like a
really good Republican he really I'm not
I'm not saying that as a joke it really
is but what I look is I guess what hurts
me the most about Barack Obama is the
missed opportunity because he did have
that giant personality that's what I
mean he could have changed things and he
could have been the guy to say no to big
money and change things forever but he
did and that's what I feel badly but
that's what I mean there I don't know
that we'll ever in our lifetimes have
another guy that will excite everybody
like that so the system should have
changed more but maybe I'm just a
dreamer two things there were two guys
that that
least and that we won in 1972 who got
his ass kicked George McGovern it was a
real like we can't be in Vietnam and
we've got to take care of four people
and I don't know why these are our
priorities and what the hell are we
talking about right this is what we do
in this country and then whose legacy he
was continuing that guy was murdered in
1968 so a my father my father worked for
both those guys and and you know and
Bobby Kennedy was like that was a
transformative candidate that was a guy
who got it and and maybe it was the
murder of his brother that changed him
because he definitely changed
politically he was a tough
anti-communist crusading son of a [ __ ]
for a long time but he kept the
son-of-a-bitch part and that's the part
that would have stuck around is that
Bobby Kennedy was not interested when he
if he had won and fought for the things
he believed in having Republicans mad at
him would not have bothered him not
concerned sometimes it's better to judge
a man not by the friends that he has
made but by the enemies he keeps that's
right and and I got no problem I did a
lot of PU fight with these Republicans
you willingness to call Michele Bachmann
crazy and all her ilk that makes me like
you yeah I don't think that that and the
only problem is is the danger as a guy
like Chuck Todd in that clip when he
says that the the lousy nature of
American discourse yes is that he can't
count that like the doesn't count
equally eventually calling the crazy non
thinkers crazy non thinkers it's not a
disillusion of discourse that's in fact
at this point an inflation of discourse
yes
you